actress Ella Blair's revelation that she
has multiple sclerosis is being met by
an outpouring of support the 46 year old
star disclosed her diagnosis and an
emotional Instagram post it was liked by
nearly 90,000 people she writes I am
disabled I fall sometimes I drop things
my memory is foggy and my left side is
asking for directions from a broken GPS
the post is bringing new attention to
multiple sclerosis and dr. Tara Narula
is here with the symptoms and the
treatments Tara good morning good
morning bianna multiple sclerosis or MS
is a nervous system disease that can
cause pain and numbness to loss of
vision and motor functions nearly 1
million people in the u.s. live with a
disease there's no cure but treatment
can help manage symptoms and slow its
progression you almost had me fooled
actress selma Blair most famous for her
roles in films like Legally Blonde and
cruel intentions I do like it I think
all the time is back on set for a new
project and facing a new challenge
Blair posted this selfie Saturday
revealing she was diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis back in August she
writes I am in the thick of it but I
hope to give some hope to others and
even to myself
neurologist dr. Fred Lublin we know that
it's an abnormality of the immune system
but we don't know what sets it off in
those affected by MS the body's immune
system eats away at the protective
covering of nerves disrupting
communication between the brain and the
body studies suggest the risk of
developing the disease is increased by
both genetic and environmental factors
including smoking low vitamin D and
adolescent obesity ms affects women
about three times as often as men and
that ratio actually has been going up
there are hormonal possibilities that
are being investigated but not yet
entirely clear why that difference
exists what do we have to talk about
Blair is in her mid-40s researchers say
most people are diagnosed between ages
20 and 50 with a wide range of symptoms
there are some people who may go through
their entire lives and never knows they
have MS and then there's some people who
can have very severe disability from the
disease and everything in between other
public figures with MS include Ann
Romney Jack Osbourne and Montel Williams
we have 15 different treatments that are
on the market at present that alter the
course of the illness we have lots and
lots of individuals who lead normal
productive lives as Blair writes I want
to play with my son again I want to walk
down the street and ride my horse I have
MS and I am okay
Blair plans to continue her work
starring in the upcoming Netflix series
another life by putting yet another
public face on Ms Blair could help
others to recognize potential symptoms
and meet with their doctor so great to
know that the son was continuing with
her work as well what are the symptoms
that people should be looking for Terra
there can be a lot of different symptoms
ranging from fatigue to loss of vision
or double vision loss of bowel or
bladder function
a sensation of numbness or tingling in
the face arms or legs muscle spasticity
so it can be very difficult sometimes to
pick up the diagnosis because people can
have these different symptoms that can
happen over years Thank You dr. Tara
thank you